I realized I watched another show before
you recommend okay before I forget I'm
gonna forget yeah I finished mob psycho
three ah oh yeah
how was it Peak hmm
I like mob psycho a lot but I it was
kind of confusing a little bit seeing
how they handled the third season I so I
I watched season two amazing yeah and I
I remember when it ended I was like is
it gonna be another season and I saw a
discussion online that there wasn't that
much left in the manga to adapt yeah
yeah um so they it's kind of odd it felt
very uh separated yeah uh I haven't
started watching it yet yeah so I had I
mean I had kind of like a similar
opinion uh when mob cycle season three
got announced uh I remember thinking
where can they take the story yeah all
the loose Essence have been tied up uh
I'm not sure if they can do anything uh
if they can add any big plot elements
yeah that
uh are better than what they showed in
season two right because I think season
two was a pretty complete season you
know everyone they could have stopped
there and I wouldn't have really yeah
much about it exactly everyone had their
character arcs and everything like that
and then watching season three
um it felt kind of like a season-long
epilogue yeah yeah for sure it felt like
the continuation where it's like hey if
you want complete closure to all of
these characters yeah this is it yeah uh
but it didn't feel necessary like it
like it's it isn't it weird how like I
felt like these characters stories were
being wrapped up completely but I felt
like okay if you don't really care that
much about seeing it all wrap up I think
you can probably skip season three and
you'll be fine I mean I I still I still
think it's necessary I think uh my thing
about season three is that it felt it it
felt like it did an E12 episodes you
know it felt like dude that's my yeah
for sure yeah it was like one or two
episodes where I was like come on yeah
yeah let's get through it yeah like it
definitely felt like oh they are really
patting this out because they need to
make an entire season out of this and I
don't think there's an entire season's
worth of the content that needed to be
like I think nine or eight episodes
would have been yeah pretty perfect
pretty perfect yeah the way it's mop
season three I mean I guess like
spoilers the first six episodes are its
own arc there's like two episodes no two
or three episodes two or three episodes
and then there's a two or three then
there's a three episode finale yeah it
kind of wraps it all up and yeah I mean
the the six part thing and the start
felt way too long that felt that that
needed to be like three four
genuinely yeah yeah like that was too
much and then the last one was pretty
good but also drag it all felt just long
it all felt bogged down yeah um some
important things happened that I thought
were really good
um Cash Ball did you chill do you care
no I wouldn't watch it yeah
one big thing happens in it where I felt
like oh yeah that kind of needed to
happen yeah I'm sure you can think the
ending yeah the ending yeah okay that
makes more sense yeah it happened when
you said you didn't feel necessary I
actually like that was the one thing
that felt necessary yeah exactly like I
felt like oh okay what now that I've
finished mobs three I'm like okay I was
wrong I do think it was necessary I
think it was necessary just because
season three is it ended mob in the most
perfect way possible and I think you
cannot kind of like underestimate the
importance of a good [__] ending
basically where everything is wrapped up
everything is happy and just I'm seeing
that final frame
um well I just it just like
put everything together and just and
just like was able to make me be like
okay mob's over it's a [__] amazing
show from beginning to end uh did it
have its fault in like the pacing and
stuff like that maybe in some places
um I still think season two was is
absolutely MOB season two is just
tightly written some of the most amazing
fight scenes in all of anime and it's
just Banger every single episode season
three felt a little stretched out but I
still think what season three did was
absolutely necessary I think the ending
was necessary but I think again yeah
like I said just Pat it to get rid of
the padding yeah cut it down make it
quicker yeah like there's this fight in
this middle of season three right and
it's [__] insane it's it's absolutely
[__] insane but I wasn't as invested
in that fight as the fights in like
season two for example so it was very
confusing following that fight and the
the the you know the fight yeah in
season three the one that happened I was
like wait what it was really confusing I
don't know if I'm dumb yeah yeah it
seems to be an occurring problem with
you where it's like I'm having trouble
following these spices that's manga
manga I have trouble following fight
scenes uh in the anime I was like what
but yeah I mean it was good I like the
ending a lot I think the ending helped
um just yeah cut it down so if you're
gonna watch season three be prepared
that it's gonna it's gonna feel like
it's really [__] slow at some points
but the ending is worth it all right
time speed got it I would say
yeah I wouldn't say that I just you know
I I do think now that mob's over it's
going to go down as a modern classic now
that it's like over over it's it's
[__] incredible and I think season
three was less actiony and it had played
more on like the characterizing which I
think was the biggest surprise of season
two right because I remember watching
season one on Mob psycho and I was just
like oh this is like one punch man but
like his younger brother right yeah
that's what I felt right yeah where I
was just like oh look at all these
flashy fights oh this is all cool and
then season two happened and then you
actually see that there there is like so
much thought put into the characters
it's not my favorite shows like ever
yeah I really like it a lot yeah and I
and I think like even though it's just
ended season three has just ended I
think it's gonna go down as like one of
like one of the best anime ever made
because it's this is this is the kind of
adaptations other manga [__] dream of
one is a complete adaptation and two
this is true two bones did not drop the
ball at all yeah in any in any part of
the adaptation you know it was just some
of the most incredible animation we've
seen in the medium of anime yeah
um still the best looking I don't know
how they made psychic fights look good
but they look really good you just
wouldn't think that psychic fights look
they went yeah they go Deco mode yeah
like that that fight in the in season
two with the teleporting guys I I still
I still remember that foreign
[Laughter]
one thing I will say uh without spoiling
what happens
um I'm glad that there was a moment
where they played the opening song once
again yes
you know
animal anime needs to bring this back I
just did anime just like talking about
anime tropes that we got tired of I
don't know why anime decided that that
was just a Cheesy thing that they should
just stop doing because I I noticed
modern and like more modern animals now
more modern anime have just stopped
putting that opening in the climax a
moment and I'm like why did we stop
doing this yeah this is [__] epic I
remember this like seeing seeing mob
three and hearing it I'm just like it's
been so [__] long why do we like when
I when that song came on I was like I
feel like I'm gonna [__] cry but
let's go oh [__] go man put your
Banger it's such a banger as well and
it's just I don't know why anime decided
to stop doing this like if they thought
it was like oh we're better than this
now we don't need to put the openings
yeah we can just use uh we can use use
like one of the tracks from the OST I'm
like no put the [__] opening back
yeah we use a random unit
solidified in my mind that Reagan is
like one of my favorite characters in
anime like bro he's such a goat yeah he
is yes I wanted to lie to me just just
[__] con my life dude give me a give
me just come on me and just give me
friendship and then become a genuine
part of my life yeah I I would happily
be conned
Reagan for sure
imagine like telling your mates that you
were [__] you will not believe who
just came he was stabbed my Reagan holy
[__] [__]
so what's the anime you're gonna
recommend to me then gone let's see oh
miss it's hard because I think you've
seen most of the anime
um most most of the anime that I would
recommend I was gonna say something like
mob but you've watched mob yeah
um if I had to throw like a curveball
like a lesser known one a lesser known
one if I just throw a curveball it would
either be
probably
you liked re-zero right yeah probably
summertime render see I I wanted to
watch it because it looked good and so
of course I it's on Netflix in Japan I
was like great I'm gonna watch it oh no
subtitles oh yeah is it not on is it on
Netflix in Japan
there's no English subtitles okay
Netflix does this for some reason uh
they they region lock stuff in Japan I'm
guessing it's an agreement with the
content yeah whoever gives them the
content that they can't have English
subtitles otherwise people good good way
to practice Japanese I mean well it is
good but then when it's a mind [__] show
you're like oh oh I don't know I watched
I watched a case in the movie is in the
cinema yeah that's fine I watched the
odd taxi in the cinema that was not fine
that was definitely not kind I did not
know what was happening yeah luckily had
watched the entire show so I understood
what was happening right right but if I
dude it was impossible trying to figure
out what they were saying yeah I I have
a rule because I do watch approximately
50 of my anime without subtitles on okay
I watch without subtitles on my rule is
is it set in high school if the answer
is yes I watch it without a problem
is it about high school am I gonna watch
it probably not like it needs to be
really compelling yeah and then there's
other like flow charts in my head that
I'm like is it also an isakai definitely
because I just every east coast show is
garbage change my mind uh yeah you're
right uh there were two I know I know
you like that that can't be an argument
because fans already know that I know I
know but that's the problem and so what
I'm when I'm ruling out all ishakai and
all high school anime I'm literally left
with like two a season yeah
95 of it I did a stream yesterday going
through like a list of uh this random
guys list of like the top isakai of all
time yeah and I have like my rule of uh
if something is what I would call a good
isekai right is it's it's the shows that
I could recommend to someone who is not
interested in East Chicago yeah like
I'll watch this yeah like I'll watch it
right yeah but I think it needs to be
good and um I came down to the
conclusion that uh there are only two
modern shows that fall into that
category one of one is re-zero the other
is mashoku tensei
watch both of them
and I'm like I was going uh I was going
down the list of everything else I was
like
skip I'm like like people were like
honestly with a cold and soup I was like
that's like just barely that
connoisseur's like a 50 50 for me yeah
in terms of like if you don't like
isekai it's like the Napoleon Dynamite
of anime yeah like connoisseur is like
yeah you need to be really integrated
into anime culture to like it because
there's no way you can just recommend
connoisseur to like a random person yeah
also season two was not that strong in
my opinion if you recommend connoisseur
to someone who hasn't watched anime yeah
they don't think you're a free yeah same
with same with like No Game No Life as
well you know which is like if you're
interested
please ignore yeah
the Lolly and stuff like that
um it's
great yeah